à la fin du 19e siècle les
mathématiques se retrouve dans cinq
états karoutchi
de nombreux témoignages contradictoires
du picador
de l'air claude koffi
ils ont été démontrées il faut qu'un
disque les monstres de fouiller tailleur
strasser contrat
allez en teamfight au monde platonicien
simple et les commenter l'idée
pire encore même la journée plus de
clés qui servait de modèle de rigueur
de vérité indiscutable
été mise à mal
pour y arriver
comme celle d'acs expire jonny quinn
offrant plus de garanties qu'elle
semblait 2 pouvoir garantir
gloss qui considérait que les
mathématiques était la reine des
sciences affirmer que la reine des
mathématiques été du coup
l'arithmétique l'étude était une
ombre
si les cours des trois axes ne sont pas
forcément ceux comme
crois qu'elles sont
sûrement les nombres ne peuvent pas à
notre égard en particulier de
l'équation un +point est égal à 2
semble être elle
une vérité
indiscutablement frais
mais cela n'a rien de si évident que
cela en fait en 1910
il logicien d'autres envoient au sol
après tout lorsqu'on voit kate
pour écrire tout un livre le plus petit
qu'à mathématiques
qui cherchait ap poser les fondements
des mathématiques et dans ses livres
il leur aura fallu 379
pour prouver qu'elle a un puissant effet
galates
370 partage pour prouver que quand un
puissant est égal à 2
et encore ça c'est si vous croyez
la logique
d'euros somme qui doit être fait
le point de base de l'équation en plus
on a étudié à l'aide
c'est que contrairement à ce qu'on
pourrait croire
l'équation est en fête
ah si bien défini
prix henri poncet est tout ce que ces
symboles une diya
qu'est-ce que ça de vrai quand même
vraiment vraiment dire casques bleus on
encaisse que le 2
qu'est-ce que c'est plus et surtout
qu'est-ce que ce symbole d'égalité
je suis sûr que vous pensez connaître
la définition de ses symboles
mais je suis ap auprès
également aussi sûres
je vais vous ne les connaissez pas
vraiment notamment parce que ces
symboles en fête
dans des définitions différentes
selon les théories dans lesquelles on
se place
aujourd'hui on va parler de l'une des
meilleures façons de définir les
symboles de cette équation
qui a été proposé par le
mathématicien italien du cpp anneaux
dont on a déjà parlé dans l'épisode
10 et pourtant
on va voir que même la réponse de
piano
edward r la bourse
alors il est apportant encore
l'émission tout cas
les distinguer les actions de piano
des actions de l'arithmétique de pme
aujourd'hui on va parler de
l'arithmétique de cannes aura pas d
actions de piano pour en savoir plus sur
les actions de piano vous invite à
aller voir cette superbe vidéo de
patience
l'arithmétique de piano elle certes
plus faible que les actions de piano
lisez aussi plus directement adapté
à faire de l'arithmétique khadir a
étudié les opérations entre les
nombres
quand on a l'habitude
et avant toute chose pour vraiment
comprendre notamment la distinction
entre les actions de piano il a été
titré perdre il faut bien voir que ce
sera très important notamment lorsqu'on
parlera
keystone la conquête du titre
que dans l'arithmétique de piano il n'a
le droit qu'à un nombre fini
décembre
en particulier les symboles un pic de de
l'équation impuissante égal à 2
sont en fête interdits
nguema critique de théâtre
pour faciliter
on pourra pas recruter un rap parce que
vous avez écrit 2 e des exactions les
inquiétudes
mais techniquement les symboles que l'on
n'a le droit de l'utiliser soutenu pour
le zéro
le signe égal
le signe +
le foie qui visitait multiplication
le ps les parenthèses la cuisse gauche
à droite
la justice du pays risquait de déverser
une marche d'escalier
un manuscrit le commerce et
verticalement lire plus qu'une première
c'est qu'aux etats-unis
techniquement on estime qu'ils
deviennent
vous n'avez le droit d'utiliser que 600
morts
avec 137 à 205 points
voir partir
l'entreprise bonne politique du ps
le reste est en fait opérateurs de
succession
ainsi lorsque j'écris quasi zéro
quand faites chauffer référence aux
rentiers naturelle qui vient juste
après 0
du coup espérons qu'avec sa lettre
même façon s f zéro
sa lettre celui qui vient juste après s
zéro
est à 0 au repos sera représentée 2
auquel on est habitué
du coup les passions après cinq égal
à 2 en fait assuré que l'iran d'un
conte de perrault
elle zéro plus zéro ppda sps
des parenthèses sont bien entendu la
clinique donc pour clarifier la manière
dont se combinent les différentes
opérations
enfin il reste encore les symboles
flèche vers la droite p
les renverser l'artiste dit à renverser
et plus le renverser ces cinq
possibilités technologiques
depuis tous
ces symboles des interprétations
interne de connecteurs logique
la flèche est une application logique
le détenu
levet renversé harper
la marque se qualifier
le traversier séville pour tous
il ne peut renverser celui il existe
enfin dernière chose qu'on va avoir des
variables
qui représente les objets
de l'arithmétique depuis un an il est
courant d'un prisonnier de la critique
piano
les nombres entiers nature
et intuitivement l'arithmétique de pme
ne peux parler que des nombres entiers
naturels contrairement aux actions de
planking que sont capables de parler
d'ensemble dentier nature
mais passons un des exemples ça va vous
aider à mieux comprendre les symboles
de la répression des auteurs
comme par exemple cet exploit
si on traduit littéralement
que si je prends n'importe quel projet
mix
de l'arithmétique de piano
il est faux de dire
que le successeur de toute cette guerre
zéro
en français le moins alambiquée ça
veut dire que 0 natale de
prédécesseurs
il n'y a rien qui vient avant 09h00
anti-naturelle
ses héros cette phrase est d'ailleurs
de le première action de
l'arithmétique deux pianos
dire qu'on a pas à le prouver on va
juste supposer vrai
comme le temps
un des fondements un but
point de départ
de la logique de l'arithmétique de
préavis
malheureusement cela arrive à
comprendre le deuxième actionnaire avec
une équipe de pl alors qu'est-ce que
ça peut bien vouloir dire
que ces symboles
les icebergs
mua si je traduis permanent ça veut
dire que pour tout objectif
de la continuité à dos il existe un
objet qu'il y ait de l'arithmétique de
clermont
quelques citi explique parts égales à
zéro
alors
le successeur de l'irak c'est égal vite
en français est plus facile à
comprendre
cette phrase revient à dire
que tout le monde prend-il naturelles
n'ont nulle et le successeur d'un nombre
anti-naturel
je vais passer plus vite sur les autres
actions de l'arithmétique de période
n'hésitez pas à mettre tout ce qui
peut prendre le temps de bien comprendre
ses actions
le troisième dit que si de nombreux
domaines successeur alors ils sont
égaux le quatrième d'itunes nombre
plusieurs os le modifie pas la valeur de
ce monde
le cinquième d'iter il exclut ses
successeurs décret qui est égale
successeur de il spécifie hayek
mais si dit-il soit 0 18 à 0
et le septième unité il soit le
successeur d'eric gerets qui est égale
fritz traille
plus x maintenant que l'on sait que l'on
va pouvoir compter que 35 pts 2
voyez comment faire
on va partir de l'axiome 5
à 0 +13 0
esther garrel
s 2
zéro plus zéro
ensuite on va utiliser une action de 4
qui ne dit que pèse zéro plus zéro
les dégâts les héros
est-ce de la paix se déroule plusieurs
autres médias haha espèce
mais à partir de ces deux égalités
est-ce qu'on peut vraiment conclure
que pèse 0 plus à 0 est également
appréciée ainsi 0
en fait il nous manque des accidents
il ne cumule toutes les actions qui ont
été dépêchés dans les opérations
de notre preuve
durant plus intégrée de il s'agit des
actions de laine logique on trouve ainsi
par exemple le fait que la négation de
droits pour toudic spéculer x ep il
existe explique non p 2 x il ya aussi
des actions spécifiques à
l'illégalité comme par exemple si il
s'est également dit très excité il a
critiqué la z
alors il s'est également classé
c'est ce que l'on appelle la
transitivité de liquidités il s'agit
d'un axiome de la logique les actions de
pernaut vient donc en complément des
actions de la logique et ça ça me
permet de définir
le symbole est bien présent
en fait le symbole égal c'est quoi
c'est un symbole quand on a le droit de
manipuler selon les règles définies
par les actions que de la logique et de
l'arithmétique de paix al gore
c'est là
mais si on prend le formalisme de
canopia planète n'y a vraiment que ça
il n'ya vraiment que quinze jours
de manipulation de symbole
de vérité mathématique sous-jacent
bref on avait trouvé 0850 étayage
s zéro plus zéro et on avait trouvé
que teste zéro plus zéro
huit filiales reste que ces euros on
peut maintenant conclure utilisant la
transitivité de l'illégalité
qui indique que ces deux égalités on
peut déduire le fait
quel plaisir ou plus et 0 est égal
s espérons que ça ira
on a prouvé qu'il aurait pu s'incliner
à 2
bon on va péter
le travail de rené maire
comme rempart il nous reste un huitième
action dans la critique de piano
qui est de loin le plus sophistiqué de
tous les actions
ces mêmes
un schéma d'action
de récurrence qui veut dire que si le
neuf unités d'actions
pour chaque formule
oui qu'on arrive à écrire
dans le langage de la critique de paix
à nos conflits peut potentiellement
dépendre
2 elle cuisine
variable
ce schéma d'action de récurent sur ne
dit que si on a réussi à trouver
fini de zéro donc c'est un risque
excellent
c'est ce qu'on appelle une
initialisation et cela reste à prouver
l'implication
les deux il explique ses muscles xl
un pic
fides stx
il s'inscrit que scène
ça c'est ce qu'on appelle l'hérédité
par l'action de récurrence appliquée
la formule i
on peut déduire de tout cela cupide et
1 045 jusque excellent
eyi toujours
alors ceux qui ont accès à vous
accorder beaucoup plus compliqué que
tous les autres et sociale plus magique
à tous les actions
grâce à cette action par exemple on
peut prouver
que qui expliciterait qui est toujours
égale à pigalle plus x
et vous propose dans les commentaires
mais c'est d'écrire uniquement dans le
langage
l'arithmétique de piano
le fait qu'il existe un nombre infini de
nombres premiers et vous pouvez utiliser
ce site
pour vous aider à écrire les symboles
la critique est pleine
alors il est pas trop dur de se
convaincre du fait
que les actionnaires a coutume de piano
son empreinte
pour les nombres entiers naturels tels
qu'on les pensait définitivement
ce qui est plus difficile à savoir
c'est parce que les actions de
l'arithmétique de canaux sont
suffisants
pour garantir que l'arithmétique de
paix à nos parle bien uniquement
il nommerait anti-naturelle tels qu'on
les connaît
eh bien la réponse est non en
particulier
on a envie de dire que tout le monde
entier naturel et sautillant en
appliquant suffisamment de fois
l'opérateur de succession
au nombre de zéros
ederson peut pas le prouver
il est même concevable
qui puisse exister dénombre 10 non
standard
qui dit vrai sur deux branches
parallels
à la branche les nombres entiers
naturels que l'on connaît
il pourra aussi très bien ne pas
l'avoir cette branche parallèle
ni l'existence
l'absence de cette branche parallèle
ne peut être déduite
des actions de la critique de théâtre
mais du coup on pourrait être tenté de
se demander
est-ce qu'il pourrait y avoir une
deuxième action a ajouté
alaric messi type de piano
pourquoi explorez existence
de cette branche parallèle de nombreux
non standard
eh bien vous invite à proposer un
thème deuxième action
la réponse est claire non
dans les commentaires
et je reviendrai sur vos commentaires
dans le prochain épisode
mais alors qu'on en a parlé d'
effraction et on a vu qu'elle était à
la fois partout
la croissance reste dense
dans l'ensemble d'entre elles mais aussi
les parents sont sous sa forme un
ensemble de mesures résultat un parti
kurde avait prouvé ça pour recouvrer
avec des bouts de tissus tous les
nombres rationnel entre 0% c'est quand
on demande si on a recouvert tout les
rationnels une infinité de bois quels
sont les nombreux qui n'ont pas été
recouvert par an qu'un bout de tissu
dans la construction garrard concerne
quasiment tous les nombres d'
irrationnelles et enfin ce cas de grosse
partie des nombres de l'irrationnel
ou plus exactement je vous invite à
essayer de vous convaincre eux-mêmes
du fait que si je prends un nombre qui
est rationnel au hasard par temps froid
racine carrée de diviser par deux c'est
une autre affaire
alors que c'est aussi à ce moment-là
que sidney promis bout de tissu que
choisie et suffisamment petit signe de
croix un demi-centimètre programmes de
mieux-être aux maîtres mots en 2010
c'est par 10 puissance beaucoup
de maître eh bien le jeu saura qu'à
partir de beaucoup furent de grands
la construction d'un garage
le recouvrement
vigueur à cette période de disette
bienne données suggèrent de faire un
épisode en record
sur la théorie de l'améliorer
malheureusement j'ai pas trop le temps
ce moment-là
maintenant c'est un vrai pilote corse le
travail mais très rapidement je peux
vous dire comment est-ce que le baiia
aussi à repenser complètement
l'intégrale
enfin la paix grâce à une sonnerie
pour la rendre
compatible avec des idées de mesures
partout et ce récit on va prendre une
pièce de 1 euro de pièces de deux
euros un billet de 5 euros
pour savoir quelle est la somme de de
ces deux pièces et lesbiennes
ce que l'on peut faire sans sectarisme
de balle mais si on a un peu plus
pourtant d'une tête
vouloir d'abord compter le nombre de
pièces qui font beaucoup moins d'un
euro
5-3
j'ai ensuite compter le nombre de
pièces qui valent au moins deux euros
seal
l'intérêt de ce qu'ils font -3 05%
aucune les containers bp s'éffondre 4
euros m d'autres termes de pièces qu'il
faut mois à 5 06 derrière rko de
l'abstention est un bon de caisse du
fonds de roulement de bière pour moi si
je regrette rien et à ce que les frci
ajoutez tous les nombres de l'obtenir
12h23 + 2 plus simple plus simple plus
souvent et même s'il s'agissait bien de
tenir exactement le bon résultat
eh bien l'intégrale de la dette
consiste à faire ça que j'ai envie de
retrouver la mère
selon une courbe
c est faire c'est considérer l'ensemble
des points tels que la courbe et autres
substances considérées la mesure de
cet ensemble il a considéré l'ensemble
des abscisses pour lesquelles la cour
des comptes dessus de 2 il est ainsi de
suite ignatieff et ses constructions de
façon plus fine rapide la ville en a
encore
tout doucement clinton
l'histoire du groupe
messieurs fait ça bien entretien
l'intégrale de le gagner qui dit
certaine manière compte lorsque la
courneuve dans les couches successives
ou plutôt comment divisant
cette façon verticale comme le frêle
intégral de finale et du coup ça ça
montre que pour calculer une intégrale
il suffit de savoir mesurer
détail d'ensemble
ensuite comment mesurer un ensemble non
c'est un ensemble de
l'ensemble mesure qui doit former
cinémaginaire compte-rendu bonnes
propriétés
comment l'union dénombrable d'ensemble
mesurables peut-être parce que je suis
ravi
c'est très clair
une fois qu'on a ça on peut définir
des mesures pas dire
des fonctions qui sont pas dit-il en
veut que l adhésion des deux ensembles
18 ans soit égale à la somme des
mesures d ensemble et ce qui est assez
amusant c'est que toutes ces théories
la mesure qui permet à quelques-uns
théâtre est en fait à la base et
toutes les théories de la probabilité
en fait une probabilité c'est quoi en
tournée on dénature une probabilité
c'est une nuit
et que la mesure de tout l'ensemble de
tous les éléments possibles
est égale
moi tout ce que je racontais la cci
niveau
au nord -8 3%
je n'ai pas compris
ce normal illusionniste fr me demande
pourquoi cela pour éviter de tirer un
rationnel est égal à zéro sachant que
la ville propose une façon de terrain
pour assurer un suivi de prendre tripoli
formant picchu aléatoirement canadiens
paie surtout tenu à ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est qu'il ya différentes
façons de définir des probabilités en
fait il n'existe pas de probabilité
absolue
il existe tout un tas de probabilité
possible on peut considérer celle qui
est considérée dans l'épisode
précédent c'est la probabilité de gm
associé à la blessure de danny
thompson les mesures d'ensemble 0 % de
grévistes
meursault se rend en ville monsieur
amical à reims
du coup ces mesures total égal à
penser que cette probabilité est du
coup je peux tirer truc seront en mesure
de le gagner c'est ce que j'ai fait dans
les deux précédentes ce que propose
des génisses et faire signer un autre
mesure de travail qui est notre
probabilité définir autrement
et je vous invite vraiment aller voir le
paradoxe de bertrand blier
m heureusement il n'y a pas d'équipé
détenu du meurtrier dans le plan
d'ensemble qui montre très bien
monsieur eux la notion de probabilités
pas définir comme celui qui est en fait
de différentes façons
de qui finira la probabilité sur un
ensemble de capteurs d une demande si le
fait que la cour ne délibère et de
dimensions degrés un pic le fait
qu'elle recouvre le plan la réponse à
cette question est non bien exemple
très amusant qui est un exemple du
mouvement brownien d'une
généralisation de la marche à
tottenham
c'est mathématique
nb pour la qualification très bonne
vidéo
sur les marchés
la gloire du mouvement brownien du
mouvement dans le corps
et une fractale et c'est même une
fractale dimension locale maisano couvre
pas tout le temps ne passe pas par tous
les points du plan mais ça ne passe pas
loin de tout point de plus en plus
exactement si vous prenez n'importe quel
point du plan
alors vous pouvez montrer quel point du
territoire
le mouvement brownien la bassée neuf
montées de fois infiniment prête à
mettre en pratique tout
du point de vue positif
mais avec 3 et tf1 ne passera pas
exactement par le poids que vous avez
choisi donc le mouvement brownien c'est
une courbe qui va passer arbitre entre
de tous les points du plan mais qui ne
va pas à recouvrir son style le plan
alex s amuser me demande pourquoi ce que
j'insiste sur le fait que
une fête pleine mesure un point qui
égale à zéro est valable que dans la
théorie de looberghe comme si la
théorie de l'etec est encore très long
ils demandent notamment à ce que la
théorie de la dengue a été avalisée
helsinki escient au filet un passant
d'un point de vue technologique sciences
comment on fait pour savoir les choses
qu'est-ce que valider une théorie
en physique un peu plus ou moins
validées les théories avec des
observations qui confirme encore et
encore mais en mathématiques il n'y a
absolument rien duchesneau
théorie mathématique je ne peux pas
être validé sa sympathie
il est assez perturbant quand on n'est
pas habitué à cela l'impression que
les mathématiques s'est joint à la
vérité un truc indiscutablement
j'espère que vous avez montré
notamment avec les exemples de la
réflexion de piano et on verra bien
d'autres exemples dans les épisodes à
venir il n'y a rien d'absolument
mathématiques tout dépend des actions
que l'on a choisi
et certains on sectionne sont plus ou
moins populaire les actions que les
matelassiers reprennent bien accepté
pour cela prendre comme point de départ
de leur théorie et d'autres sections
que les mathématiciens
la théorie de la dette tous ceux qui
fondent
l'analyse est assez un truc ultra
accepté on peut dire que c'est une
théorie acceptée par la communauté
mathématique pour très grosse partie
du comité d'accueil
en revanche et je rebondis ainsi à la
question de pour ange bleu la théorie
des séries divergentes dont je vous ai
parlé dans l'épisode
2 4
et 5 dans l'épisode scor
c'est super ça swingue stable
ça correspond à des actions que a
beaucoup de mathématiciens notamment à
l'école préfère-t-on durée et c'est
pour ça que la cession en fait il faut
pas faire ce que j'ai fait les épisodes
4 et 5 à l'école puisque à l'école
ce sont des actions
j'utilise qui ne sont pas rares
communément acceptées par les
professeurs à l'école et c'est
vraiment pas grave que de rejeter
certaines actions les axonais n'ont rien
de fondamentalement droite comme le
dirait en réponse claire et la journée
prix n'est pas vrai
elle est un montage reste incertain car
il est parfois vaut mieux prendre
certains actionnaires géométrie et
parfois il est plus pertinent d'utiliser
d'autres sections de la journée prix
ok c'est pas mal comme ça que je
conçois les mathématiques mais on aura
l'occasion de revenir bien plus en
détail
sur cette notion de diversité en
mathématiques dans les prochains
épisodes j'espère que vous avez
laissé plus d'un an que l'on a parlé
de la critique de piano on va pouvoir
parler
du théorème
début de chalutiers l'ultra perturbe
notamment par rapport l'équipe de
pierre si vous avez aimé cette épisode
pour celles dans lesquelles commentaire
partagé pense à vous abonner ensuite
l'épisode de cette performance
j'espère
la prochaine fois
bon en même temps je dois thématiques
propres propositions de ce langage que
toute démonstration l'arithmétique
pourrait être réécrite avec toute
cette étape initiale
peut-être comme que nous avons de plus
sans rien dire de plus
garrido de rennes avec lui c'est à dire
ce que je peux normal
alexandre était complet
mais non le conseil fédéral par contre
il faut revoir ce
par exemple pour la chaîne
les qualités de son côté m trop quand
même
ernst pour le jardin